it's about
to get a little chilly in here
what's the coldest you've ever been
well today we're cranking that down a
notch
today you're heading into absolute
zero territory is
absolute zero really colder than outer
space
what could we do with such a low
temperature
and how badly is this going to hurt
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you touched absolute zero
so besides sounding like an awesome band
name
absolute zero is the lowest possible
temperature
in the universe at minus 273.15 degrees
it literally can't get any colder it's
so cold at absolute zero that the very
atoms have stopped moving that's
really cold even the freezing vacuum of
space is only
minus 270.41 degrees
so absolute zero is colder than the dark
reaches of outer space and
today you get to be our guinea pig
and touch something cooled down to
absolute zero
i know right what an amazing opportunity
now let's say we froze a small piece of
metal
down to absolute zero temperature
would you mind picking that up for us
as you pick up the piece of metal you'll
find
that it's absorbing all the heat from
your hand
your hand is covered in moisture
which is being robbed of all its heat
and
it begins to freeze once the temperature
drops below zero
okay you can let go of the metal now oh
you can't
well that's because the water freezes
inside the tiny pores of your hand
and the surface irregularities of the
object
so you'll get stuck think of it like
when you lick a flagpole in winter
but a lot more painful and
if you try to remove the piece of metal
the flesh of your hand
will rip off with it no kelly clarkson
just remember you volunteered for this
next blood vessels near your skin will
begin to constrict
this will reduce the blood flow to the
affected areas and
help keep your vital organs alive it's
like your body puts up a roadblock
the problem is this lack of blood supply
and
oxygen to your skin can cause damage to
your cells
at absolute zero the piece of metal will
lower your cell's temperature
until they are so cold that the liquid
inside them freezes this would create
sharp ice crystals and damage the
structure of your skin cells
and brace yourself it gets worse
you can expect even more damage to the
lower layer
of your skin aka the dermis
not to mention all the damage to your
hands muscles and
tendons okay uh maybe we should call it
quits on this
well because you were such a go-getter
you decided to hold on to the absolute
zero metal as
long as you could and as a result you've
got
fourth degree cryogenic burns on your
hand
this will eventually lead to gangrene
and
extensive necrosis do not google that
trust me
with your injuries there's only one way
to save you
amputation so besides
maiming you what could we actually do
with absolute zero
well hopefully the study of absolute
zero temperature will lead to
discoveries in cryogenic research the
field of cryonics
seeks to preserve whole human bodies at
ultra low temperatures
around -196 degrees
yeah that's not as cold as absolute zero
but if we can get a handle on how to
work with such a low temperature
we can use this knowledge to prevent
your body from
crystallizing and your vital organs from
being destroyed after you're frozen
which
makes us wonder what if we were able to
nail the cryogenic freezing process
what if everyone on earth froze for
1 000 years well
that's a story for another
what if